il y a quelques jours je faisais une
vidéo sur le Xiaomi 13 pro je suis un
maîtresse pro que j'ai reçu que j'ai
pris directement en Chine donc ici j'ai
un logiciel plutôt chinois j'ai pas le
logiciel européen même s'ils m'ont
installé bien évidemment les services
Google que je retrouve directement ici
donc ça c'est bien c'est chouette je
voulais absolument qu'on fasse un
premier point pour regarder ce que ça
disait au niveau photo vidéo pourquoi et
bien parce que c'est la première fois
pas réellement la première fois mais pas
les s'il y a première grosse fois en
tout cas qu'on va retrouver en France et
bien le partenariat avec Leica jusqu'à
présent c'est Huawei qu'il avait le
partenariat avec Leica il est arrivé ici
il y a chez Xiaomi sur ce Xiaomi 13 pro
même si on l'a vu sur le Xiaomi 12S
ultra il y a quelques bonnes semaines
néanmoins c'est vraiment le gros
lancement ici avec les câbles donc on va
regarder dans cette vidéo ce que raconte
ce Xiaomi 13 pro au niveau de la photo
très gros focus photo on regardera
également un petit peu de vidéo très
très rapidement et puis bien évidemment
on attendra d'avoir la version française
définitive qui devrait arriver fin
février début mars pour pouvoir
effectivement vous dire réellement ce
qu'il en est alors pour l'instant c'est
une version uniquement chinoise mais bon
voyez la version française arrivera donc
on y va vous êtes prêts vous êtes prêts
allez on y va
on récapitule très très très rapidement
en fait vous avez trois capteurs à
l'arrière vous avez un capteur principal
de un pouce c'est ça qui est intéressant
on a un pouce sans coprocesseur ça veut
dire qu'en fait c'est votre Snapdragon 8
GN2 qui va tout gérer à la différence
qu'on avait sur le 12 s ultra où on
avait un coprocesseur qui permettait de
faire le calcul parce que le dragon lui
tienne 1 ne faisait pas le calcul tout
seul il arrivait pas donc là il y arrive
assez vachement cool c'est la fameuse
caméra Sony MX 989 on a également un tel
objectif de 50 mégapixels et également
ultra grand-angle de 50 mégapixels
autant dire qu'ici on a du 50 50 voilà
c'est un triptyque votre ultra
grand-angle fait aussi office de
maquereau à 5 cm d'écart et puis surtout
on a deux types de couleurs Leica on va
voir la colorimétrie Leica authentique
et la colorimétrie Leica vibran vibrant
un peu plus de couleurs un peu plus
dynamique ok vous êtes prêts allez on y
va j'ai tout shooté en dynamique sauf à
quelques moments où je vous expliquerai
je vous montrerai alors ça c'est dans un
resto il y a pas beaucoup de lumière
c'est vrai que pour l'instant c'est pas
hyper hyper glamour on entend ultra
grand temps on va pas très rapidement on
peut zoomer dans l'oubli sur de la
nourriture ok on peut le faire là on
arrive plein jour alors c'est pas mal
c'est vraiment pas mal moi ce que j'aime
bien déjà vous voyez c'est que on a bien
du détail tous les côtés l'image est
belle que ce soit dans le soleil qui
sont un peu partout alors ce que je vais
venir voir je me rendais pas compte de
suite de suite je l'ai vu parce que j'ai
quand même vachement regardé ces images
et bien c'est que on est un petit peu
sur le jaune ça tire un peu sur le jaune
là où l'ultra grand-angle va tirer un
petit peu plus sur le blanc on a une
petite différence de colorimétrie sur
les deux on peut venir ou non c'est en x
3 x 10 j'ai fait du X 30 et le X 70 je
crois voilà c'est celui-là le maximum
qu'on peut faire très honnêtement je
vous le conseille pas on peut jusqu'au x
30 x 30 c'est pas dégueu au delà du X 30
on va éviter le X 10 et la sécurité ici
regardez en fait vous le voyez là c'est
le capteur principal le fameux capteur
de 1 pouce et dès que vous switchez ici
alors c'est marrant parce que j'ai
l'impression qu'en fait ici l'ultra
grand-angle est un peu plus jaune mais
vous verrez ce que j'ai bien une photo
dans la neige qui vous montre un peu
autre chose néanmoins je trouve que
l'image est bien l'image fonctionne bien
alors forcément sur ultra grand-angle on
perd un peu en définition sur les côtés
mais le reste il y a que le centre de
l'image fonctionne bien bon pareil au
niveau du zoom voyons on peut venir
zoomer un peu x c'est bien x 30 on peut
et au-delà de ça on évite alors ça c'est
dans la et vous l'avez vu je crois que
j'enfonce des portes ouvertes et là
c'est un petit peu jaune voyez et
lorsque je passe sur l'ultra grand-angle
alors là il est jeune pour le coup c'est
bizarre il y a des trucs qui sont un peu
différents je n'arrive pas trop savoir
pourquoi là c'est mon grand-angle je
suis jeune l'ultra grand-angle je suis
un peu plus jeune et lorsque je me
rapproche ça va ça fait le taf toujours
un peu les mêmes choses qu'on vient de
dire ici grand-angle ultra grand-angle
là c'est un peu plus jeune sur le grand
angle et un peu plus blanc donc un peu
plus bleu sur l'ultra grand-angle ici et
il y a des moments je sais pas pourquoi
j'ai un rendu qui est un peu différent
je sais pas vraiment donc là vous voyez
c'est plus jeune sur le grand angle
ultra grand-angle est un peu plus blanc
mais dans tous les cas ça fonctionne
donc vraiment c'est assez différente de
colorimétrie entre le grand angle et
l'ultra grand-angle là c'est pareil
c'est plutôt bien c'est mon fils qui est
dans la neige vous voyez il fait le
malin là c'est jaune là c'est plus blanc
on peut venir se rapprocher alors j'ai
fait quelques photos en maquereau ça
c'est pas de la macro hein ça je fais du
zoomer directement dans l'image ça c'est
sympa et ça c'est de la macro alors moi
j'aime bien la macro alors moi j'aime
pas trop mais là c'est vrai sur 50
mégapixels ça fonctionne bien alors il y
a vraiment qu'une zone qui est nette
vous la voyez cette zone là tout le
reste n'est pas net donc c'est pas
évident de venir shooter de voir
vraiment ça donne net mais je trouve que
le rendu est quand même est assez
qualitatif ça marche pas mal ça c'est
aussi de la macro j'aime bien je trouve
c'est très naturel c'est beau c'est
clair c'est limpide ça c'est encore de
la macro de la macro et de la macro
toujours donc je trouve que vous voyez
c'est pas mal une fois de plus vous avez
que ça donnait tout le reste est flou
après c'est pas facile de venir shooter
une petite branche comme ça donc vous
voyez les photos dans la neige elle
fonctionne bien on pourra amener des
souvenirs simplementochrome là vous
voyez j'ai zoomé un peu trop c'est
compliqué mais le rendu est quand même
Cali est plutôt sympa et j'aime bien
donc voilà une fois de plus toujours un
peu les mêmes critiques alors là au
niveau de la caméra de selfie je suis
pas hyper hyper fan c'est ce qu'on
retrouve beaucoup chez Xiaomi ça vient
beaucoup trop lisser les pots et le
rendu pour moi il est pas dingue
regardez j'ai l'impression d'avoir une
tête d'avoir 15 ans 15 ans avec la
beubard comme ça ça c'est fou mais après
dans l'ensemble les photos sont plutôt
bien elles fonctionnent bien elles sont
chouettes voyez vous avez tout vu j'ai
fait des photos lors d'un concert pour
venir dans des conditions de luminosité
un peu plus difficiles c'est ce qui de
use à la Coopérative de Mai à
Clermont-Ferrand il y a des choses qui
sont bien peu moins bien vous voyez déjà
ici là il a un petit peu plus de mal au
niveau de haute lumière ce qui a
l'éclairage en douche qui vient
au-dessus j'ai fait beaucoup de choses
on cherchait vraiment avec le zoom et
pas beaucoup de lumière il y a du bruit
70 c'est quand même relativement
dégueulasse là-dessus mais c'est pas
anormal voyons où je suis je suis quand
même un petit peu loin donc c'est c'est
pas déconnant si vous voulez ça c'est
l'ultra grand-angle enfin le luminosité
très honnêtement on va on va éviter on
peut venir zoomer jusqu'à un X 10 et je
dirais mais au-delà de ça vous avez du
bruit c'est pas parfait il y a quelques
images que j'ai fait que j'ai trouvé
plutôt bien vous voyez dès qu'on vient
zoomer trop c'est compliqué en plus il
bouge beaucoup à ce moment c'est un
concert hein vous savez c'est un peu
plus un peu plus compliqué alors on
verra lorsque je testerai sur le
firmware français lorsqu'il arrivera
dans quelques semaines maintenant on
verra ce que ça ce que ça raconte on
arrive à faire des choses donc on arrive
à avoir des souvenirs mais il faut pas
trop venir le pousser en conditions de
faible luminosité donc je passe un petit
peu ça ces photos là sont pas mal là
voyez je suis venu zoomer je sais pas
combien faut 10 fois 30 peut-être x 30
j'en sais rien il y a du bruit mais ça
sent quand même pas trop trop mal c'est
pas trop dégueu ces photos là je les
aime bien je trouve qu'elles sont passe
pas trop mal vous voyez là c'est bien
c'est assez clair on a bien le visage on
a bien du détail on peut venir mais on
va pas venir zoomer on peut regarder
comme ça je trouve c'est quand même
assez sympa pour venir regarder alors
sur écran d'ordinateur mais également
sur smartphone ça fait le taf vous voyez
il y a des choses qui sont très très
chouettes comme ça donc là c'est assez
net en fait j'aime bien ce qu'on arrive
à sortir en terme d'ambiance ici et de
lumière vous voyez là c'est pareil je
suis très zoomé alors il y a l'éclair
sur eux mais je trouve que c'est pas mal
franchement il fait un boulot qui est
quand même pas mal on verra
effectivement sur des conditions
urbaines lorsqu'on viendra vraiment
faire un test un peu plus poussé sur la
photo mais tel qu'il est là c'est pas
mal et il s'en sort quand même plutôt
bien regardez là c'est chouette on a
bien les visages les expressions là il y
a rien de cramé bien que vous ayez
l'éclairage qui vient de côté là c'est
pareil ça fonctionne c'est clair c'est
beau pour moi ça marche on a bien la
tête du public en bas donc le taffer est
rempli là je vous montre on se balade un
petit peu à Paris on va regarder un peu
ce que ça raconte on a des photos qui
sont pas mal alors une fois de plus
grand temps que ça fonctionne ultra
grand-angle on va perdre un petit peu en
précision mais c'est pas anormal ici on
peut venir zoomer un peu voyez que le
zoom est quand même préservé jusqu'à un
bon x 10 c'est quand même vachement bien
ici on peut venir s'amuser davantage
chercher des panneaux j'ai vu ça c'est
un peu chercher différentes scènes la
regarder je pars de là on va venir
chercher ces petits bonhommes ici là en
gros plan en venant zoomer donc on vient
on se rapproche on se rapproche on
arrive quand même avoir des choses quand
vous avez beaucoup de lumière quand il y
en a un peu moins il fait un peu la
gueule là c'est pareil alors là j'ai
fait avec le temps TIC et là j'ai fait
que le vibrant je montrerai un peu plus
loin il y a des choses qui sont quand
même pas mal il faut vraiment trouver ce
qui vous plaît ce qui vous plaît pas
vous voyez grand angle ultra grand temps
que j'ai changé entre authentique et
vibrant je vais vous montrer vous allez
mieux vous en rendre compte dans
quelques instants là c'est pareil alors
je suis venu chercher du détail en
venant zoomer bon toujours un peu les
mêmes critiques ici toujours la caméra
de selfie qui me fait une tête d'enfant
de 15 ans très honnêtement alors après
vous avez deux modes vous avez un foin
et un x-08 qui va shooter un peu plus
large c'est le même objectif qui fait
les deux bon voilà il y a pas grand truc
de fou ici mais ça marche aussi deux
types de colorimétrie pour moi il y a
pas de trucs de dingue sur cette caméra
de toute façon de selfie qui lisent
beaucoup trop à mon goût je suis venu
chercher deux trois petits trucs ici
mais c'est pas foufou alors ça ça c'est
marrant parce que vous voyez on va venir
chercher le détail parce qu'en fait le
détail se cache dans le visage ici on
arrive à le récupérer et c'est ça que je
voulais vous montrer même si une fois de
plus vous voyez on part quand même de là
bon à tout de suite c'est c'est beaucoup
moins terrible mais c'est une fois de
plus normal avec un x 100 le Point
Virgule avec les deux types de
colorimétrie ça c'est l'original et ça
c'est la vibrant voyez un peu plus
soutenu un peu plus coloré mais on va le
voir sur une photo un peu plus loin ça
c'est l'original que je préfère là il
Brandt vous voyez il y a une vraie
différence plus jolie sur celle-là que
sur celle-là pareil ici donc là on est
en original Leica original et là on est
donc je sais pas si vous vous rendez
bien compte de la différence on va plus
se rendre compte ici au niveau de cette
boutique qui est sur un jaune un peu
pétant donc là c'est l'original et là
c'est la vibrown qui va être un peu plus
soutenu après ça reste très léger c'est
pas extrêmement criard c'est du laica
ils sont pas là pour faire des trucs qui
sont dégueu dégueu ça marche c'est sympa
donc je trouve que bon l'idée pas mal
moi je préfère une fois de plus
originale à la viande mais il y en a
pour tout âge chacun donc ça c'est ce
que je voulais vous montrer un petit peu
au niveau des photos je vais vous
montrer maintenant un truc au niveau de
la vidéo je suis venu shooter sur le
concert pour vous montrer un peu ça
raconte sur cette image là et ben je
trouve ça pas mal du tout regardez là je
trouve que pour venir shooter du concert
c'est quand même pas mal le zoom est
très smooth regardez je viens zoomer
c'est hyper smooth donc si vous voulez
avoir un suivi la stabilisation elle est
vachement bonne je tiens ça à la main
j'ai un tremblement essentiel ça bouge
fatalement et ben là c'est quand même
vachement cool je me suis mis le
quadrillage pour me repérer et m'aider
et bien je peux venir zoomer dézoomer je
suis cadré je suis dans le truc c'est
smooth c'est doux donc pour venir
shooter franchement ils ont fait un
super boulot ici Xiaomi je trouve ça
vraiment vraiment bien une fois de plus
ce capteur de 1 pouce est vraiment et
lorsque je je prends un peu de recul ça
marche alors là je vous le fais dans des
conditions de nuit on se retestera plus
tard lorsqu'on aura effectivement le
firmware européen le firmware français
mais ce que je vois ici je trouve pas
mal donc je trouve qu'on a quand même un
rendu qui est très très cool ce que je
retiens en fait ici si vous voulez c'est
que le boulot est bien fait de la part
de Xiaomi le capteur de 1 pouce marche
bien je trouve qu'il y a de très très
jolies photos j'attends de voir une fois
de plus comment ça va arriver en France
et est-ce qu'il va y avoir quelques
modifications mais la base est là la
structure est là on a le stade dragon 8
GN2 on a tout le travail qui va
permettre de faire on a ce capteur de 1
pouce qui est là on a toutes les techno
qui sont posées au niveau de la RAM au
niveau de Rome donc tout est raconté
maintenant c'est qu'est-ce qui peut être
modifié un peu d'un point de vue
logiciel est-ce qu'il y a des choses qui
vont être un petit peu changé pour
l'Europe oUI NON à quoi ça va ressembler
je trouve que les photos sont bien elles
sont très belles je suis pas pour autant
en train de de taper le cul par terre en
me disant c'est fou ce truc est fou ça
marche bien ça marche vraiment bien j'ai
une fois de plus hâte de voir ce qui va
arriver avec cette version française ça
me plaît maintenant on va aller chercher
plus de choses un peu plus tard au
niveau des conditions de faible
luminosité ce que je voulais plutôt
chouette mais dans tous les cas vous
avez un appareil qui est hyper négatif
je regrette peut-être que l'image soit
pas assez typée j'en sais rien après on
peut venir chercher des choses avec les
gars il faut gratouiller davantage en
tout cas les premières images que je
tiens à vous montrer ici je trouve
plutôt chouette plutôt bien réussi on
voit un peu les limites du smartphone
mais malgré tout le résultat est
vraiment norable et on continue à voir
cette progression de Xiaomi en photo
avec notamment ici les partenariat avec
les cas je pense que vous en pensez
est-ce que vous aimez ces photos est-ce
que il y avait des critiques à formuler
moi ce que j'ai vraiment formulé comme
critique c'est la différence entre le
grand angle et ultra grand-angle au
niveau de la colorimétrie je trouve ça
con parce que quand on a un partenaire
comme Leica on s'attend à avoir la même
colorimétrie une colorimétrie maîtrisée
ici c'est pas le cas une fois de plus on
a pas les mêmes capteurs c'est pour ça
en fait que vous avez vraiment cette
différence mais ça aurait pu être
peut-être récupéré d'un point de vue
logiciel j'en sais rien en tout cas
c'est pas le cas vous voyez il y a une
différence qui est vraiment flagrante
une qui est plus jeune l'autre qui est
plus bleu bon voilà il y a ces petits
trucs là qu'on se dit ah c'est un peu
con c'est dommage ce que j'aime vraiment
par contre trouver vraiment bien pour
une fois c'est cette macro qui est super
bien le capteur de 1 pouce fait le taf
on peut venir zoomer dedans quoi sont un
peu luminosité c'est pas mal il faudra
voir sur des scènes un peu plus urbaines
qu'on viendrait chercher plus tard
lorsqu'on aura la version française en
tout cas moi je trouve qu'il y a un un
boulot il y a une belle progression
dites moi vous ce que vous en pensez en
bas dans les commentaires et puis bien
évidemment on reparlera de ce Xiaomi 13
pro lorsqu'il arrivera qu'il sera
officialisé en France et puis d'ici
quelques jours on va parler aussi
l'expérience logicielle avec mi-way ici
je suis sur mi-way 14 on va regarder
quelle est la différence entre new et 14
et new why 13 est-ce que mi-way 14
apporte vraiment beaucoup de choses oui
ou non donc pensez à vous abonner si
vous ne l'êtes pas déjà et puis pensez
bien évidemment à actionner la cloche
pour être notifié dès qu'une prochaine
vidéo arrivera et ça c'est vachement
bien voilà je vous embrasse prenez soin
de vous et à très bientôt Ciao